grand moment de stress cet après midi à
la nasa l'agencé spatiale américaine
attendait de connaître le sort de sa
sonde inside à quelques secondes de se
poser sur mars
très loin d'ici à 146 millions de km de
la terre
lancé en mai dernier la sonde inside est
un robot géologue autonome équipé d'un
outil de forage de sismomètres et d'une
série de capteurs sa mission explorer le
sous-sol martien
son coût 1 milliard de dollars pourquoi
il ya de la vie ici et pas sur mars
est ce que le cas de la planète est
encore actif avant de répondre à ces
questions il fallait classe on ne se
pose en un seul morceau sans l'aide de
la nasa
à 14h40 insight c'est donc détaché du
lanceur puis la sonde est entré dans la
même atmosphère martienne à près de 20
mille kilomètres à l'heure protégé par
un bouclier thermique 7 kilos mais de la
surface déploiement du parachute
éjection du bouclier le système
d'atterrissage est libérées tout près du
sol la sonde se détachent les
rétrofusées s'allume insight se déposent
doucement au sol à 14h54
pour couronner le tout la sonde envoie
une photo sa première du désert de sable
qui l'entourent dans les prochains jours
insight déploiera ses capteurs solaires
puis il faudra attendre deux ou trois
mois avant que ces instruments
scientifiques fonctionne si tout va
comme prévu sa mission s'étendre sur les
deux prochaines années
ici normand grondin radio canada
montréal